hi this is Avinash and welcome to the
next edition of our web analytics videos
this one's on a topic that is near and
dear to every one's heart and it's creep
formance indicators I don't think that
you can go very far in web analytics
without hearing the name kpi's
brandish'd about and all its excitement
in glory and yet I think that for the
most part people are a bit confused
about what kpi's are how to select them
how to make them more actionable what
value do they add and and all of those
other wonderful kinds of things and so
in this video we're gonna do to two
parts of this video and it's going to be
my attempt to start at the sort of the
ground floor and explained from the from
the very beginning with what these
things are and how do you understand and
study these animals called KPIs and how
can you how can you avoid some of the
pitfalls that that sort of befall many
of the other people and get your own of
web analytics journey after a flying
start so this is gonna be a lot of fun
and regardless of what role you have
regardless of whether you work on the
SEO side of things or PPC PR online
email marketing just or traditional
website analysis I really think that
these two videos are going to be very
important and relevant to pretty much
any persona that touches your website so
I hope that you're gonna have fun and
let's get going
the very first thing that I wanted to
sort of cover is set a baseline from
what a KPI is and of course when in
doubt there's only one place we can all
go and that's the great Wikipedia so
obviously media has a wonderful entry
for key performance indicator and their
definition of KPI is actually a good one
and it states that KPIs are financial
and non-financial metrics used to help
an organization define and measure
progress towards an organizational goal
so a bit bit higher my dear you know and
glorious perhaps but nonetheless a
really really nice definition of what a
KPI means again regardless of what
channel you apply to it and regarded
what persona is gonna end up using it
and to me I think that if it's the back
from the definition I was joking with
John Marshall that you know keep your
eyes are like heartbeat is a KPI that
that I can measure using a stethoscope
and like put it against your heart and I
can see if you're alive or dead you know
that the beating of the heart is the KPI
that indicates and something very
critical about your body you know
another KPI is the temperature of your
body that I could take using a
thermometer and in this case the KPI
gives a different sort of read and it
tells me if you're feeling well or
you're running a temperature and if
you're running a temperature how high is
it and do we need to just take an
aspirin or call a Fire Brigade to put
off you know your your 101 or 10:00
temperature or well at that temperature
you probably need other help but
regardless so in its simplest terms I
encourage you to think of kpi's as as
those kinds of indicators that sometimes
tell you something is drastically wrong
with the case of the heartbeat or at
other times can help us understand some
interesting things about about the
process that you're measuring and of
course I I had to sort of come up with
my own definition you know and into me i
am i hope that that you'll agree that
this is sort of a very simple easy to
understand metric and balances two very
important things and and the definition
is kpi's are measures that
help you understand how you're doing
against your objectives and then really
these two things are very important to
words at the end the first one is
measures and the other one is objectives
and I really do believe that objectives
are very critical to understand before
you go on a KPI hunting mission so so so
keep that in mind you know measures that
help you understand how you're doing
against your objectives are is exactly
what I think kpi's our key performance
indicators and let me give you a couple
examples you know may mix up let's have
some fun and and understand a couple of
KPI them and not be tough of your mind
and and further sort of make this
concept more concrete and here's here's
a great example of course there's a KPI
library on the web you know surprise
surprise and then here's a really great
KPI a percent of naso comeall infections
and then in the way that the KPI is
defined I think is very much along the
definition we've just proposed and it is
how many inpatients acquire infections
inside the hospital you see see there
it's it's a measure very clearly defined
and tied to an objective which is that
people coming into the hospital with no
infections of any kind should not get
infected once differently Hospital so
absolutely a glorious wonderful example
of what a KPI is and here's another one
we were doing a webinar and and of
course
much to my delight there were a number
of KPIs that I could see or in the
dashboard that was presented right here
and and the one that I thought was most
beautiful and delightful was attentive
the percent of people who were on the
webinar at that given moment in time who
were paying attention to what I was
saying is this very very good metric
it's a clear measure tied your
objectives that were giving a webinar
and everybody should be paying attention
there's a really wonderful metric again
another one that's not totally tied to
our daily web jobs but nonetheless makes
the concept concrete and let me give you
a last example of a KPI and a lot of
people don't think about this when
they're measuring website
but I really love it this is a KPI
that's actually used by blinds.com and
Daniel as the CM over their shared this
data with me and his KPI is gross margin
per visitor so he really measures this
hardcore for people who come visit his
website and and over time as you can see
over the course of two years nearly two
years the KPI has gone up into the right
again measuring the outcome which is
improving the gross margin for every
single website visitor clearly defined
KPI that that Daniel is measuring much
to the success of blinds.com so those
are just three examples that hopefully
help you make the definition more
concrete but let's actually before we
dive too deep into other examples of
KPIs that you could use and you should
be using for your web business let me
walk you through four distinct
attributes of a great KPI and before we
get into too many examples and and this
is sort of a test that I encourage you
to apply every time you go out there and
choose a KPI for your business
and the very first very very very very
critical one is I think great kpi's are
uncomplicated two things all the time
very I saw this in KPI engagement
couldn't go to engagement KPI and and
essentially had seven variables some
were multiplied divided by the other
ones and and some were to the power of
something else and at the end of these
six or seven variables and number was
spit out and it was so complex that
there's just no one except the creator
of the KPI who could understand what he
actually meant or what the number that
got spit out meant but worse than that
the other problem with this KPI was that
if even if the number got spit out and
you understood what the definition was
there's just no way on God's green earth
they can understand which of those
variables or what the root cause was of
things happening well or not happening
well in fact most of the time some of
the variables were up the other word
there were other were down and the
number that got spit out was essentially
flat so you could wrongly assume that
everything was great with the business
when in reality that was not the case at
all so I strongly encourage you when you
pick kpi's to make them uncomplicated
who understands what the KPI is worth
definition of what it's measuring then
it is highly unlikely in today's
distributed complex organizations where
we're trying to create a democracy that
you'll succeed in your mission of making
a company data-driven and use that KPI
it is highly likely that complex kpi's
essentially become auto deleted when you
send them out and nobody can understand
or take action from them so try not to
be cute at least initially and create
metrics that are uncomplicated solving
for is an organization to use the KPI to
take action and not just you yourself so
it's a great first test that you should
apply
and the second one is KP I should be
relevant there is this that is this
believe today that best practices work
for everyone there even are books
recommending KPI saying oh here's a
cookie cutter mechanism if you are a
seller of widgets or you're a social
network or your your your your you know
a blog then here are the KPIs that you
should use and and that's it and you
should not worry about anything don't
hug your pretty little brain and just
copy-paste these and and happy birthday
to you and and this really is not true
in my experience I find that KPIs are
very unique to each business and the
objectives of each business remember our
definition measures is the first word
objectives is the last word in fact to
me best buy in Circuit City make a great
case where essentially on the surface
both of these businesses are exactly the
same they sell electronics pretty much
exactly same electronics look at the
look at the top navigation bar in fact
for both of these businesses and they're
essentially could be a copy-paste of
each other and yet when you think about
the objectives of what these business is
solving for they each have an extremely
different business strategy online
Circuit City is heavily heavily into
getting people to come to their stores
look at look at the free shipping on
orders
25 and up and chew or choose 24 minute
in-store pickup today and there's
nothing about sort of store pickup right
there in the header so circuit city's
core strategy let's drive people to the
store Best Buy Score strategy let's get
people to buy online and yes we do have
an option to pick and store but that's
not really the core strategy so go back
and try and understand what you're
solving for in your business and it's
okay to take inspiration from others but
if you simply copy/paste metrics then it
is highly likely that they might not be
relevant to you and you won't be able to
make as much progress in your business
as you could possibly want to have
happen so remember that kpi's should be
relevant to your business
the third one is that the third awesome
rule is they should be timely very very
important I was doing a job interview
with a with a company a couple years ago
and and I asked them you know how come
your performance in the last quarter was
actually spectacular you made a ton of
money and what they said to me is ah yes
yes we would like to understand that
we've just executed the query that will
can help us understand what's happening
with that metric increased revenue and
that query will return it results in two
months I'm not even joking admittedly
this is a big business but if the answer
to your KPI takes two months to find
it's highly unlikely that you would be
able to take action that you need
remember the web moves at a pace of
light and it's very important that the
metrics you created is most of them not
all of them but most of them are
available in a timely fashion so if you
want to make decisions on a weekly basis
then creating KPIs that take a week to
collect is highly unlikely that you
would have time left over to find
insights and take action so remember to
apply the test that KPI should be
available to you be able to be computed
and available to you in a timely fashion
and in and in time enough so that you
can then look at the KPI and then
further spend some time understanding
analyzing segmenting it so you can take
action on it so timeliness is very
important
the last rule is they should be
instantly useful and this this rule is
because I've seen so many KPIs they just
want to make me cry because I just it
takes like 10 minutes to explain what
they are and and then they and this
really no way that we can make everyone
understand what the numbers are showing
and they're not really instantly useful
and here's a great example of what I
mean by instantly useful this is a
report from click tracks one of my
favorite tools and as soon as you look
at this report it's not a data puke of
the top keywords that are driving
traffic to my website what it is showing
me are the keywords that are
statistically more significant now and
are actually sending me sending me more
traffic over the time period I'm
analyzing or less traffic in the time
period that I was analyzing so as soon
as I look at this report immediately I
can take some action and and this is
really what I recommend that your KPIs
be on your dashboard your senior
decision-makers should be able to look
at your code KPIs and and just by
looking at the numbers with an
up-or-down or flat they should be able
to sort of understand at least some
semblance of what kind of success is
being driven from those KPIs or or lack
thereof so look for KPIs that are
instantly useful rather than KPIs that
show up in a dashboard and and then it
takes you two and a half years to
understand you know if what what what
what trends were or or in order to make
them more useful so so that's another
important rule that I have so let me
give you an example of a KPI that sort
of meets all four of these rules and my
my hope is that as you go about your own
business you'll apply these rules to the
KPIs that you have
so to close this video I want to walk
you through some examples of what I
think are a great kpi's that that I
think have some universal appeal to most
businesses that exist out there but what
I also want to do in this part is
actually encourage you to think beyond
your standard clickstream stuff if
you've seen the other videos or all read
my blog or buck or anything that you
read mark motive I'm sure that you'll
know that I'm a big fan of use of web
analytics to do concept and this idea of
using multiple sources and and I think
this is a big mistake people analysts
and marketers make on the web where we
don't use multiple sources to create KPI
so let's get going and let me exceed
some ideas in your mind that you can
build on
and of course the worst most obvious KPI
in the world in the universe is
conversion rate and it's highly likely
that it is relevant for your business
and then you know traditionally what we
think of conversion rate is you know
ecommerce they did you know what's my
conversion rate and that's the graph you
see on the left here it's one point four
one percent for this website and then
you know am i making revenue in this
case five thousand euro so very
traditional metric applies everywhere so
you measure conversion rate look at the
absolute value and it's very very useful
but the other thing I want to tell you
quickly before we go to the next one is
think of conversion rate as having many
many different kinds of outcomes that
you could measure it could be leads
submitted it could be something that was
viewed on your website it could be of
course ecommerce for a retailer so think
of conversion rate more broadly but of
course for e-commerce websites this is
exactly what you want to measure
and the next one is is one that I think
is a hidden a KPI that I think that many
people don't measure which is called
average order value and this is a
wonderful wonderful KPI and and in this
particular ecommerce website you can see
the average order value is 345 dollars
and this really a great KPI because it's
great to know that you had one point for
one conversion rate but you know over
time measuring average order value could
tell you if you're much better able to
sell products and services on your
website or if you are more merchandising
and upselling and cross-selling in
promotional efforts that you have are
having the kind of impact on what people
end up buying on your website so
remember you could have a one point four
to converge percent conversion rate for
four for months and months and your
average order value could consistently
be going down the toilet or keep
increasing so another different way of
understanding if as with each visitor
who places an order on your website are
you doing a great job of upselling
cross-selling promotions or or or
helping people find the products and
services they need so I love this KPI
average order value because it gives me
another diagnostic measure for
effectiveness of my website
um and and these are two of my favorite
measures also on the e-commerce realm
and they could be used for non
e-commerce websites as well and they are
called days and visits to purchase I'm
sort of on the record as saying that
most marketers and website experiences
are created with this the concept of
one-night stands in their mind where you
know yeah you just come to my website
and buy right away in this session and
it said you know nobody sleeps on the
first date and let's really know how the
web works either people come to your
website explore it they have the dance
you know if you go out for dinner with
you and and put something to your to
card and then go away think some more
play hard-to-get and maybe on the 3rd
tell him they actually buy something on
your website so days and visits to a
purchase are a great KPI because they
help you understand true customer
behavior on your website so in this case
on this website you'll notice about 45%
of the people buy on the first visit but
then the rest of the people actually buy
on subsequent visits in fact about 4%
traffic buys after 9 to 14 visits and so
this is a great way to understand
customer behavior on your website but
then also help you understand in segment
your data so you can understand what
kinds of people do buy in the first
place what products are they buying and
then whatever these people who take
multiple visits to go buy what campaigns
are driving them what products do they
buy and and and why is it the debye
after many visits it's Gale gets you a
great understanding of customer
experience but more than that helps you
evolve beyond the one-night-stand mind
said that so many marketers
unfortunately have in the web and
there's two visits is the corollary of
that you know you could have 10 visits
in one day and this sort of frames it up
as how many days does it take and this
data is actually for a travel website
actual data for a travel website and and
there's nothing more toxic you know in
in terms of nuclear decay then airline
tickets they become expensive with every
passing minute and yet on this travel
website where that sells airline tickets
only 60% of the people bar on the same
day in fact almost 40% of the people
this big block of people at the bottom
actually bought between eight days to
120 days later it is astonishing so
these people made a known choice to
prompt a a very expensive price for the
ticket rather than buy it on the same
day and save a ton of money and and it's
very important that you understand you
know why do these people do this and
what destinations are they going to and
and can I do something like help these
people save their itineraries or ping
them and send them an email reminder
that the price just went up another 10
bucks so I can get them to come back
sooner and buy from me so this is a
great KPI that gives you a peek into the
customers mind and gives you ton of
actionable insight to improve your
website's a love love these two metrics
days and visits to purchase and here's a
great place where I measured this
particular metric and in this case I
segmented by different kinds of
acquisition strategy pay-per-click
direct as well as affiliates and you'll
notice that different people behave
differently so people who come in to
pay-per-click actually take greater a
lot of them take greater than three
click three visits to buy while my
affiliate people who I'd actually
thought would need a lot more convincing
to buy on my website 64% of them buy on
the first visit and this is exactly what
I meant by by the power of this metric
to give you a great peek into the
customers mind and then go back and
optimize your affiliate marketing
gambits in this case actually because I
did not think the affiliate marketers
marketing campaigns convert fast my
landing page did not have actually so
right away Add to Cart buttons and
things and write off as soon as I got
this is a boom I put a lot of call to
action on that those landing pages so
excellent action on my website right
away improve many conversion rates a
very good KPI
and to other kpi's if your website is
not e-commerce related is loyalty and
recency so for example I'm I use the New
York Times website and let's assume for
a second it has no ads or the BBC
website which also has no ads and in
your content website no car ecommerce of
any sort no lead submissions nothing
just content and in that case I like
measuring visitor loyalty [ __ ] how
frequently do people visit our website
and it's not just measuring average
visits to in a month and that's really a
average metric that really lies and and
does not give you good data look at the
distribution some kpi's you have to look
distributions and in this case I would
go back to my CMO and say look 39% of
the people came once to my website even
though in this case average visits to in
a month were just two but there were
about forty another thirty forty percent
of the traffic right here the very
bottom that visited my content website
between nine and two hundred times a
month so some amazing this bucket of
really loyal people to my website and
they're coming again and again and again
every day actually on the bc website
this is me I go there all day long again
and again being a political junkie and
and you can understand these you can you
can create a goal around this to say
month over month for our visitor loyalty
distribution KPI are we getting better
or worse so in this case actually we got
slightly worse in July because the
number of people who only visited once
went up from 61% to 64% so so that's a
great way to measure success by using
metrics like visitor loyalty for non
e-commerce websites and here's another
one called visitor recency so let's say
you're running a social networking
application where the only purpose of
your application is so people friend
each other and send applications and do
super perk and other annoying things
nonetheless you you don't have an
e-commerce model yet or any advertising
model to speak off how do you measure
success of this particular business well
measure recency are you actually
creating such a sticky and engaging web
sites that people come to it every
single day they can't wait to get to it
and in this
the metric and data shows is that 66% of
the visitors to this particular social
networking website actually visited in
less than zero days ago it's phenomenal
because they can just go back to their
executives and say look our application
is still sticky so engaging Microsoft
why don't you give us a four hundred
million dollar investment for one
percent stake in our company because we
are so awesome well they can use this
metric to do that because indeed 66
percent of the traffic these are the
people have nothing better to do then
send their spend their life super poking
other people and sending them
applications so phenomenally actionable
KPI for a non ecommerce business that
helps you measure the health of the
business and if they are successful in
their strategy so really wonderful
metric
and the next one I wanted to share with
you it comes from a survey based
mechanism and it's called task
completion rate and I'm a big fan of
this metric because on any average
website you'd probably have two percent
conversion rate
what is everybody else doing how do you
measure success of the 98 percent of the
people who are not converting on your
website and I really like this metric
pass completion rate and essentially it
helps you understand get beyond you
obsession of this thin blue line at the
very bottom you know that's your 2%
conversion rate and help you understand
what's happening this big red the
ninety-eight percent of the people and
if your website has delivered any value
to them it's a great KPI measured using
surveys and essentially what it is is
the answer to the question were you able
to complete the task on our website
whatever desk you were there for you
could be there for e-commerce submitting
lead donating money to our presidential
candidate read the latest news
downloaded by you apply for a job look
at market model videos be convinced of
our greatness doesn't really matter why
you came to the website task completion
rate gives the power of the customer so
when they leave the power to the
customer so when they leave the website
at the end of the visit we can show them
a short survey and say why were you here
that helps us understand primary purpose
and the second question is were you able
to complete your task so in this case if
I was running this website I know that
74% of the people converted sorry were
able to complete the task then my job is
to figure out what the other 26% were
doing and why they were not able to
complete the task so this is a great way
to measure success of every single
person who's on your website and and I
mentioned in my past market motive
videos that I've teamed up with
iperceptions to create this survey for
free and that anybody in the world can
use totally free and you're on exit when
people exit your website it shows the
survey and ask helps you measure task
completion rate across different primary
purposes and it's a very very actionable
metric because rather than you and me
John and Michael and I sitting around
arguing about what should we fix next on
the market motive website we can simply
take the content of this survey the
answers from a questions
when they tell us what tasks they're not
able to complete and use that as an
input to improve our website so we're
not only solving for re girls inside the
company but we're solving for our
customers or on our website it's a
really great way to measure task
completion rate using this free survey
and in turn in blue I'm sorry
improving customer satisfaction because
if you were able to complete your task
your satisfaction in this piece of data
is seventy-seven but if you were not
able to complete your task your
satisfaction dropped dramatically and
you can help influence and improve that
and the firk you survey will help you
understand why people are coming here
are the reasons in the blue and and what
each of those people's task completion
rate is so you can identify things you
should be fixing so in this case clearly
the people who are not able to complete
their tasks so a bunch of them were
there to buy and only 39 were able to
complete the task which essentially is a
crime against humanity because this is
an e-commerce website and everybody
should be able to buy who was there to
buy so boom right away you understand
why conversion rate is zero point zero
zero zero zero zero one percent yeah
real actionable insights
and I believe this is the last example I
wanted to take you out of your website
and help you understand your performance
in context of your competitors and in my
last KPI uses competitive intelligence
in order to understand your performance
and I love this metric called share of
search and it's essentially like what
what traditional marketers have been
using and they didn't take all its share
of shelfs I mean I mean Walmart or or
you know my Procter & Gamble brand
manager I really want to know what my
share of shelf is for Pantene shampoo in
in in Walmart and Target and all these
other kinds of stores well why not
create such a metric for the ultimate
shelf in the world which is a search
engine essentially Google Microsoft
Yahoo that dominate acquisition
strategies for most websites and to how
much a share of that shelf do I have
when people are looking for me and you
can use competitive intelligence tools
to understand that so in this case I can
say okay what are the top key websites
that send me traffic how much share do I
have of search traffic so for singular
from Google Yahoo Microsoft all these
other engines and in the case of
singular it's nine point three three
percent traffic they have shared traffic
from Google while Verizon it's actually
ten point six percent from Google so
Verizon gets a lot more traffic from
Google tenders singulars in this context
singular you know would cry a little bit
because as every percent of difference
here on this report is hundreds and
thousands of searchers so really a
singular can get can create this KPI and
track it not only track it as a point in
time which is what you're seeing on your
screen but actually measure trends over
time too and in this case you'll notice
Verizon is the blue line and singular is
the orange line and and for some reason
single has been on the right path over
months and months so they're nine
percent traffic from Google is great
because they keep increasing over time
while if you look at Verizon they have
started to make big mistakes and started
with literally drop off the radar in
this case for the last few months a very
very troubling
if I was Verizon and if I was singular
this KPI sheriff search would
immediately get me a big bonus from my
boss so this is a great way to measure
success by using a metric that's
available externally and and is gonna
give you another example of Google
insights for search I wanted to see how
much brand impact I'm having how much
share of searches top-of-mind I am in
terms of my customers when I look for
laptops so I said you know I like think
that's a lot I have an ex 61 which I'm
very very fond of and I wanted to know
if ThinkPad is due how think that the
brand is doing over the last few years
compares to latitude which is the brand
of Dell MacBook Air which is the brand
of Apple of course and vaio which is the
a brand of Sony and and try to use this
KPI which is the the search the number
of queries at a search engine to measure
if my brand a dollars being spent online
in offline are causing people to look
for my laptop my brand of laptop and and
unfortunately what it turns out is both
Dell and ThinkPad have been going down
over time and that's precipitously in
some case and that's a sort of very very
sad and what it shows is magma caravan
it's launched boom to honor people
Tanna interest totally beat the heck out
of both latitude and think pad and yet
now it's sort of misses Steve Jobs is
coming down to earth a little bit more
over the last few months but but notice
the Green Line that's the Sony Vaio
and and in they've done a marvelous job
of having a nice upward slope over the
last four years and consistently doing
the kinds of things that are required to
stay top of mind in customers and and
have lots and lots of search qualities
be generated in Korea demand for their
products so again a great KPI if I were
Sony Vaio's brand manager to show value
that my ad dollars are creating in the
general ecosystem while everybody else
is going down I am going up so the
another wonderful KPI and that you can
create from competitive intelligence
data so I hope that you've learned
very actionable insights about what
kpi's are what kinds of rules and
regulations are tests you could apply to
find great KPIs for yourself and I hope
that I've inspired you with the examples
of KPIs that are sort of not normal and
not used by many people to find your own
interesting and innovative KPIs that
will help you find actionable insights
from your web analytics data your
comparative intelligence data and your
survey data so I wish you all the very
best thank you